hey guys it is the 9th of May today and
although I can't be playing uncharted 4
at the moment because I'm talking to you
I do have a story about it so let's get
into that one digital foundry have
posted their technical analysis of
uncharted 4 and they've called it the
technical powerhouse we've been waiting
for digital boundaries analysis doesn't
run short on praise as they say this is
a must play experience that delivers the
rare mix of pitch perfect gameplay and
high-end visuals the set pieces are more
impressive than Maps larger the
characters and environments more
detailed and the gameplay mechanics are
richer than ever before uncharted 4 runs
on the latest version of naughty dos
proprietary engine at 1080p and 30 FPS
for single player and 900p and 60 FPS
for multiplayer digital foundry add is
that this is the best image quality
they've seen in the console game to date
praising the rendering of drake's
character model right down to the way
his chest hair moves in the wind you can
check out the full report over on your
again next up free super mario items are
on their way to Minecraft Wii U on me 17
the Super Mario mashup pack will include
things like a premade Super Mario themed
world 15 pieces of music from Super
Mario 64 and 40 themed skins it will
arrive as part of a free update and will
be included on the minecraft where you
gain disk when it launches on jun 17
nintendo vp of publisher and developer
relations Steve singer added all the
world and item textures in the game will
also be redone providing players the
opportunity to create their own super
mario theme two locations within the
walls of minecraft
finally Capcom have said that next
month's razzy spin-off umbrella core is
just a warm-up to what they have them
still in the latest earnings reports the
publisher said the spin-off shooter is
closed a warm up to the full-scale
offensive a planned for the second half
of the year this might refer to resident
evil 7 which is rumored to be in
development but it could also be
alluding to promotions regarding the
resident evil spirits is 20 anniversary
this year umbrella core launches on jun
21 for pc and ps4 and you can pick it up
for thirty bucks let me know in that
comment section what you think is the
best looking come for game of this
generation be sure to head to gamespot
for stories on battlefield one and mafia
free that is everything you have for you
today be sure to check out the awesome
uncharted before content we have on site
and I will see you again tomorrow